was lange währt wird endlich gut unter
diesem titel sind politiker von cdu csu
und spd offenbar die einigung der
parteien auf einen koalitionsvertrag
der geschäftsführende innenminister der
für die cdu verhandelt hatte thomas de
maizière zeigte sich am mittwoch
zufrieden kurz vor seinem statement war
bekannt geworden dass er einer neuen
bundesregierung nicht mehr angehören
wird
ich bin sehr stolz und sehr dankbar dass
ich in drei schwierigen ressorts in
diesem land dienen durfte
ich freue mich darüber dass eine neue
stabile regierung zustande kommt und ich
wünsche meinem nachfolger im amt des
innenministeriums alles gute und viel
erfolg
auch die verteilung richtiger
regierungsressorts wurde am mittwoch
bekannt
dazu csu generalsekretär andreas scheuer
das wahlergebnis zur bundestagswahl hat
uns alle nicht zufrieden gestellt die
jetzt die letzten tage am tisch gesessen
sind und deswegen ist die csu sehr
zufrieden mit einem super
innenministerium das angereichert mit
bauen wohnen und heimat und einem
starken investitions ministerium aus
verkehr und dem bereich digitales und
auch mit der außenpolitischen kompetenz
der csu mit dem wichtigen ministerium
für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit also
rund um ein gutes paket
im bereich befristung von arbeitsplätzen
und in der gesundheitspolitik sind nach
ansicht des spd generalsekretärs
hubertus heil fortschritte erzielt
worden
ich bin erstmal froh dass die
spd-zentrale ressorts für sich markiert
hat es gibt eine chance beispielsweise
in der europapolitik zu neuen aufbruch
zu kommen in der finanz und
steuerpolitik wird sozialdemokratische
handschrift auch in ressorts da sein und
dass wir bearbeiten soziales
unsere produktion weiterhin durchsetzen
können die reform des gesundheitssektors
soll eine kommission übergeben werden
hieß es ebenfalls am mittwoch